I do so much that the biggest trophy I
own now is that book the biggest trophy
I don't know it's not the book is
selfish what's in the book hmm it's what
like I don't give a [ __ ] if that sells
one copy
honest to god man like like my what I
did and that's what I hope people
understand your life in the journey you
put yourself through there's no there's
nothing more than that and that's all I
want people to do is realize that you
have to struggle you have to struggle
the bigger the struggle the bigger the
peace the bigger the suffering the more
peace I'm not just saying this because
you hear but this book is valuable this
book is very valuable it's valuable to
people like anybody that you know I mean
the biographies are very always valuable
when you get to see the mindset of a
person who's done things that you
haven't done you get to understand like
that they're overcoming sort of the same
sort of situations in their mind that
you are same insecurities and pitfalls
yeah everybody's going through it man
yeah everybody that's that's one thing I
say I'm blessed that way that my story
there's no colour involved in it it's a
human story about struggle and I happen
to be in so many different situation
that so many people can relate to about
struggle that I guarantee you mark my
word you read that book there will be a
section of that book that resonated use
hardcore it will make you think if if
you're not ready to think about your
life and think about you know where you
can be and think about what you haven't
done the books not for you if you're not
ready to self no tell you really self
reflect and hold yourself accountable
for where you're at and where you're not
the book is not for you is real I've
read a lot of self-help books and I've
listened to a lot of self-help books on
tape - and a lot of it's just some of
them that I have to shut off I have to
shut off a quarter way and I feel like
someone's lying to me I just like you're
bullshitting me you're just saying
things this I'm not this doesn't
resonate with me it doesn't it's not
working like I'll give it a chance
I'll give it a chance but if I'm you
know half hour in two hours in it's
still the same nonsense I don't feel
anything right I'm gettin itchy
listening to you you know I just want to
pull the headphones off and I'll just
kill it stop it this is the total
opposite this one man I was I was good I
was running
extra miles so I could stay with the
headphones on and the the thing that I
think is gonna happen with this book is
people gonna get it they're gonna get a
hold of whether it's an audio book or
the or the book book and they're gonna
they're gonna recommend it and then it's
gonna spread like wildfire this is a
powerful book this is a real self-help
book this is like this is a real one
like it's not like someone orchestrates
this whole thing like what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna become a motivator I'm
gonna be a personal influencer I'm gonna
be that guy that goes out there and
tells people you can optimize your life
and there's so many of those [ __ ]
guys out there right yeah That's not me
I know this one dude I ran into him
recently I ran into him at this
restaurant he's fat as [ __ ] he's got
this big old belly and I know he does
these these motivational things and I'm
looking at him like what are you talking
about man right weak right look at your
body look at your own temple look at
that your meat vehicle you're riding
around this [ __ ] doughnut around your
waist is just he was eating shitty food
look soft and like wake up [ __ ] so many
people are doing that now man people are
talking this noise exactly and I see him
yeah I know him I'm not gonna say names
but I know I'm like man dude you know
why my life is miserable right now cuz I
can't go on your show right now your
podcast if I didn't get at you this
morning so I cannot talk to people
unless you're thin unless I'm authentic
cuz I used to be the most unauthentic
[ __ ] on the planet
now I had this voice man saying oh no
I'll call you well if I lie to you about
something even a white line hey yo Joe
guess what dude I [ __ ] lie female
like that wasn't real like it will
bother me that background you know so
another thing I didn't which funny about
this book stuff man I didn't set out to
write a book like literally man when I
was 24 years old on accounts fat's
praying for cockroaches eating doughnuts
and drinking milkshakes I did not plan
on doing this all I wanted to do was
change the [ __ ] reflection in that
daggone mirror this is all this to Bob
it's it's it's a byproduct of of that
and that's that's the funny thing about
like it was like oh my god David Gaga's
but you know what tell you I'm like what
the [ __ ] that's why it works though
unbelievable it works because you really
did do it you really
to do all those things and you show how
you did it and you're not using any
[ __ ] theatrical jargon no you're not
you know you're you know you're not
saying a bunch of buzzwords can you live
the life of an actualized person I can
show you how and you look in this guy
talking he's gonna neck like a pencil
and is his body's just frail I don't
even understand adversity you don't
understand overcoming this is not the
secret you know is it about the law of
[ __ ] attraction yeah exactly same
traction here brother
this ain't no attraction to your man
yeah I love nonsense this is no nonsense
no nonsense this is a real self-help
book man this is the real deal that's
how you self-help you self-help by
people have done it and you learn what
they did and you realize there's no
shortcuts right and then you learn to
embrace that no shortcut mentality and
enjoy enjoy the suffering and the grind
of n what we talked about earlier
there's no [ __ ] finish line doesn't
exist you know what's funny about that
is I have people now so when I was in
the worst part of my life those people
want to bring you back in those people's
like like you can see who you hang out
with like when you and your worst and
when you're trying to get better with
what makes it hard to get better is that
you are hanging around people who let's
say you are an alcoholic you hang around
people who drink and I say you want to
stop drinking those people want to bring
you back in like I used to be this guy
this guy who was know who wasn't worth
anything now those people who are still
there they're sixteen seventeen eighteen
thirty years ago they try and get you
back there so the hardest part you guys
see who you're hanging out with man you
gotta hang out with the people who you
want to be like the most yeah people
will definitely drag you know jacket
down and especially if you around
someone that makes a lot of excuses and
I was failing
oh those is just like they're they're
the opposite of inspiration they're like
a vacuum uh-huh just sucking it out of
you why are you doing that today man
right right you get up again so early
why are you doing this why are you doing
this the people you hang around it will
suck the [ __ ] life out of you yeah
sometimes just gotta be a long man
get your [ __ ] in and then there's also
people that are gonna be around that are
always failing and always [ __ ] up and
they're always coming to you to try to
get you to help them exact on a giant
burden yes
ever look in the mirror and get their
own [ __ ] together and always looking for
external health that's right
I always looking for story people don't
want to go in deep man all the answers
are inside of you it's a very primitive
way a college book is written as
primitive this it's very barbarians it's
how we all think it's not it's how man
once walked the earth and then we get
all soft and all these computers and
[ __ ] we say we start going away from the
most powerful thing we have is our
[ __ ] brain is our mind and we don't
use anymore so you know it's like
everything has to be so quick yeah you
use your mind when it comes to certain
things right but what you're saying is
you don't use your mind when it comes to
enduring exactly that is it
you can't Google that [ __ ] right hey let
me Google how to suffer no Hank Oh be in
there bro
anger being there they go be in there it
doesn't exhaust find some water real
cold and what's interesting is that that
is a mind thing and people think of mind
things they think of calculating
mathematics that there's no literature
no no no there's many aspects of them
that's it don't overthink it yeah no
ever think it put your shoes on lace
them up it's how you got to do my friend